guys I'm making this video out of
necessity there's a large part of me
it's been the prevailing part of me as
of late
that makes me not want to make this
video because it's unfiltered because
it's not ready what I want to say isn't
totally polished I haven't thought of
all the shots that I'm gonna use I
haven't thought of the lenses that I'm
gonna use and this perfectionistic part
of me
needs to die because it's getting in the
way of what I want to do with my life
I've known my whole life that over
complicating things thinking about them
a million times planning things
endlessly pales in comparison to doing
the thing
with an unrefined decisiveness right now
I'm supposed to be editing a completely
different video but it's taking me so
long to do it and I'm growing so
increasingly frustrated with myself that
I had to pull out this camera and talk
to you guys about my own inner struggle
and hopefully you guys can relate this
is why I made this channel it's because
I'm trying to live and get out there as
much as I can gain new experiences and I
will always have sort of an aha moment
that I want to share with you guys it
happens all the time talking about life
and the best way to live it it goes so
deeply into the core of my being I never
stop talking about this type of stuff
but what ends up happening is I have
something very genuine I want to say
then I put on a whole charade around it
that sometimes by the end of it what I'm
saying isn't as genuine it is turned
from a core idea that is extremely
authentic into a little bit of a
production and that's not all bad a good
example of this is probably my favorite
video on the channel in action is a slow
death that video from beginning to end
is probably my favorite video on the
channel by far everything that I said
was carefully considered not from a
place of trying to sound smart but it
was something I genuinely felt with
every fiber of my being and the shots
and all the imagery that I use to convey
this message came naturally it was like
oh of course it'd be so cool if I did
this and you know I feel like that would
be such a good moment if this happened
but there are other times where I kind
of forget what I'm doing you know I sit
here because I have a deadline for a
sponsor like this video by the way I'll
sit here and it's like oh it's time for
me to sound smart now here when you
think about your life I watched older
videos of mine where there's periods
where I just feel very based and I just
don't really care about how I'm coming
across and I preferred that way more and
it just remind me of how over
complicated I'm making everything and
you're probably the same way because I
have a feeling that I'm not alone with
my over complication I actually feel
like procrastination and when you're not
living your best life
it's just a form of over complication I
use the gym example all the time but I
think it's a really good example when
you really want to go to the gym maybe
you've gone to the gym very consistently
in the past and you start thinking about
oh how you should be going to the gym
more so you start looking up you know
the best workout split to do the best
supplements workout clothes and your
mind goes down this rabbit hole that has
nothing to do with working out because
all working out is is going to the gym
and lifting heavy stuff all you need to
do to get jacked is show up to the gym
three days a week
push more weight than you did last time
and eat more food than you usually do
gradually that's all you need to do and
I guarantee you you can have the best
physique of your life on beans and rice
the only catch is you show up to the gym
and you try as hard as you can to push
more weight than you did last time that
is it and the person who does that day
after day week after week month after
month will be in an infinitely better
place than the person who knows the best
workout split the best supplements yada
yada yada the best diet to be on and
maybe guiltily convinces himself to go
to the gym like a few times within that
time frame that person is left in the
dust and I feel the same way about
making content right now to be honest
I'm watching so many people who you know
oh make worse production value videos
that I do and they're killing it you
know they are crushing the YouTube game
because they're making content they're
showing up and making videos and
sometimes it misses and sometimes it's a
banger but they're just showing up
they're putting in the work whether an
idea is super refined and it's their
favorite idea of all time or not they're
just showing up talking to the camera
and put putting in the work and it's
really got me thinking about how there
is no substitute
for putting in the work there is zero
substitute and any sort of over
complication or procrastination it's
just denial you're denying the reality
that you will eventually have to sit in
front of the camera and talk to it
you're denying the reality that you'll
have to drive to the gym and push heavy
weights you're denying the reality that
you're gonna have to sit down and do
your taxes and file them and it's going
to be very difficult and very boring but
it's a reality that you cannot escape
from no matter how hard you try you'll
be faced with the suck shit's gonna suck
and the sooner you realize that and
embrace the suck for what it is you
fully submit to it then right around the
corner there is the Redemptive element
of it you embrace the suck and then
you're transformed by it you feel good
about yourself because you're no longer
living in this anxious denial you're
sitting down you're doing the hard thing
and you're moving your life forward it's
that simple changing your entire entire
life being a good person being a strong
person developing virtue eliminating
Vice there is not a thing that's
complicated about it but it's not the
same as it being easy it's very
difficult it's very uncomfortable it's a
sucky thing but the sooner you can
embrace the suck the sooner that you can
make something out of it you don't have
to shroud your life in this anxious
regret this denial this running from oh
what if doing my taxes is less fun than
scrolling Instagram it is
but is scrolling Instagram for 16 hours
fun
I don't think it's very fun it's like
there's dopamine or something right
there's something going on that keeps
you doing it but your soul leaves your
body you start to Decay as a human being
that's not fun you're not living in this
really good enriching empowering
existence when you're doing that you're
living in denial but instead of living
in a triumphant pain you're living in a
degenerative pain it's pain either way
but one builds you up and makes you feel
really good about yourself the other one
makes you hardly recognize yourself
after a long enough period of time
utterly stripping you of your identity
so this begs the question
you watching this right now what are you
over complicating in your life what is
something that you want to make progress
on you know if it's a habit or a
lifestyle change or whatever what is
that thing and how are you over
complicating it what creative ways are
you employing to deny the fact that it
sucks so I implore you I beg you to take
a deep breath relinquish all that stress
from your body and put one foot in front
of the other and go do it that's it yeah
it sucks embrace it
I want to thank athletic greens for
sponsoring this video and for being a
cool chill company that lets me say
whatever I want whether or not it's
related to health and wellness as I've
mentioned before athletic greens is a
unique sponsor because I reached out to
them they didn't reach out to me I
reached out to them because I used their
products for like a year and a half or
two years or something like that
continuously and it made me feel so good
that I reached out to them and said hey
I would love to rep your stuff I am a
huge believer in ag1 and the way that it
makes me feel throughout the day and
that's because it's packed with over 75
vitamins minerals Whole Foods Source
superfoods and adaptogens with every
single scoop ag1 makes sure that you're
giving your body everything it needs to
stay focused energized healthy and
optimized throughout the day probably my
favorite thing about ag-1 is that I
essentially ditched my cupboard full of
various herbal potions and
multivitamins and whatnot in favor of
just a single scoop of ag-1 it's kind of
the simplest way to give your body
everything it needs to function well so
as usual if you want to check out
athletic greens and join me in this very
simple Health optimization habit that
I've been doing for over two years then
click my link in the description below
and you'll also receive a year's supply
of the vitamin D3 and K2 complex which I
also have every single morning as well
as five ag1 travel packs with your first
purchase so make sure to hit up that
link and thanks again to athletic greens
for sponsoring this video so guys
turn off the phone stop living in denial
go do what you need to do